y
[Música]
inicio en italia la cumbre del g20 el
primer encuentro presencial de los
líderes de las principales economías del
mundo gira en torno a temas como el
logro de 'cero emisiones' la
recuperación económica global y el
acceso a vacunas en países con bajos
recursos
todo listo en glasgow escocia para el
inicio de la cumbre climática con 26
mañana el encuentro es considerado la
oportunidad definitiva para que los
países demuestren su verdadero
compromiso en la lucha contra el cambio
climático seis años después de suscribir
el acuerdo de parís a su vez hoy
finaliza oficialmente el encuentro de
jóvenes por el clima
se agudiza la crisis diplomática entre
líbano y arabia saudita riad ordenó la
expulsión en un plazo de 48 horas del
representante diplomático libanés y
llamó a su embajador en beirut luego de
que el ministro libanés de información
criticar a la coalición militar que
lidera la arabia saudita contra los
rebeldes yemeníes desde 2015
en france 24 estamos de vuelta con las
noticias que marcan las jornadas hoy
valentina torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos damos inicio en italia
comenzó en roma la cumbre del g20 los
jefes de estado y de gobierno que
asisten al primer encuentro presencial
de las 20 mayores economías del planeta
desde el inicio de la pandemia se
enfrentan a una serie de problemas en
primer lugar de la agenda están la
recuperación económica y la crisis
climática una preocupación que se
intensifica a vísperas de la cob 26 pues
se teme que no todos los mandatarios
estén de acuerdo en la manera de
afrontar lo que se ha descrito como una
amenaza existencial para toda la
humanidad
arranca el g20 en roma en medio de
tensiones entre los asistentes a la
cumbre que parece no estar en sintonía
ante múltiples retos uy sí de ministras
vemos niveles peligrosos de desconfianza
entre las grandes potencias entre los
miembros del g20 entre los países
desarrollados y los países en desarrollo
incluidas las economías emergentes el
objetivo más importante de esta cumbre
del g20 debe ser restablecer la
confianza abordando las principales
fuentes de desconfianza enraizadas en
las injusticias las desigualdades y las
divisiones geopolíticas este tipo de
confianza será vital para tratar los
temas urgentes que se tienen entre manos
recuperación tras la pandemia
coronavirus y sus consecuencias
económicas así como concretar los planes
para hacer frente a la crisis climática
sin embargo los mandatarios xi jinping
de china y vladimir putin de rusia no
asistirán en persona un posible mensaje
de que las preocupaciones internas han
ganado la partida un punto positivo
podría ser la finalización de un acuerdo
para impuestos global mínimo sobre las
grandes corporaciones no se ha avanzado
mucho en la lucha contra la pandemia en
un frente común las críticas no se
limitan a que los países desarrollados
proporcionan suficientes vacunas a los
países más pobres sino por el
incumplimiento de las promesas de ayuda
además de 100.000 millones de dólares al
año para ayudar a esos mismos países a
hacer frente a lo que podría ser la
preocupación más urgente del g20 la
crisis climática
este es el momento de hacerlo realmente
es el momento para el dinero dinero
dinero es el momento de cumplir promesas
han prometido que realmente harán su
parte en la búsqueda de esta base de 100
mil millones de dólares por año para
ayudar a las naciones pobres en su lucha
y empuje para el cambio climático eso no
ha ocurrido cuando proclaman 6 battier
en japón los miembros del g-20 son
responsables del 80 por ciento de las
emisiones de gases de efecto invernadero
del mundo y justo antes de la cumbre
climática con 26 en reino unido- la
atención se centrará en roma durante el
fin de semana en busca de cualquier
señal de que el mundo pueda finalmente
ponerse en marcha para cumplir los
objetivos de reducción de emisiones en
el plazo previsto
faltan menos de 24 horas para la
conferencia de las naciones unidas sobre
el cambio climático con 26 en donde los
países buscarán compromisos para
revertir la crisis climática a
continuación les presentamos un recuento
de las naciones más golpeadas por las
emergencias en la última década ciclones
tormentas y huracanes son solo algunos
de los fenómenos que causaron más
estragos en diferentes partes del mundo
manuel acá no tiene los detalles
más letal que las guerras o las
enfermedades el cambio climático deja su
huella en 2008 2.4 millones de personas
fueron desplazadas por una tormenta en
mianmar 17 veces más que las
desaparecidas y fallecidas en medio de
la conmoción social que vivía el país
uno de los países más afectados en la
última década en el caribe ha sido haití
las inundaciones que provocó el huracán
sand y acabaron con cerca de 70 vidas
humanas el huracán maría azotó a puerto
rico el 20 de septiembre de 2017
destruyendo carreteras y puentes y fue
la tormenta más poderosa que haya tocado
la isla dejando 2 mil 975 muertos el
continente africano se vio tocado por el
fuerte ciclón y dady en 2019 provocando
la muerte de mil personas en mozambique
zimbabwe y malawi el mismo año por al
otro lado del mundo en las bahamas el
huracán dorian lo catalogaron como el
más intenso en la historia de la isla
llegando a las costas estadounidenses un
tiempo después y provocando la
evacuación de más de un millón de
personas en 2019 6 de los 10 países más
afectados por las crisis medioambiental
fueron azotados por ciclones el año
pasado las lluvias tocaron a múltiples
países a lo largo del mundo pakistán
registró una temporada de monzones que
causaron más de 4.000 muertes y 200.000
viviendas fueron destruidas también en
nepal las tormentas provocaron
inundaciones y deslizamientos dejando
132 fallecidos y millones de desplazados
2020 fue uno de los tres años más
calurosos registrados con temperaturas
promedio globales de 1.2 grados
centígrados por encima de la época
preindustrial mientras tanto los
expertos alertan que los ciclones
tropicales aumentarán debido a la subida
de la temperatura global vamos ahora
hasta el líbano donde se agudiza la
crisis diplomática con arabia saudita
real llamó a su embajador en beirut y
expulsó a su homólogo en territorio
saudita luego de que el ahora ministro
de información libanés criticar a la
coalición militar que lidera a arabia
saudita contra los rebeldes hutíes en
yemen desde la capital libanesa nuestra
corresponsal etel bonet nos cuenta más
a las múltiples crisis que atraviesa el
líbano se suma ahora una crisis
diplomática con los países del golfo
después de que anoche a arabia saudi
haya llamado a su embajador a retirarse
en 48 horas y prohibiera la exportación
de todos los productos y a sus
ciudadanos viajar a el líbano el
incidente diplomático fue provocado por
unas declaraciones del ministro de
información afín al partido hezbollah
que hace unos meses dijo en una radio
pública saudí que los útiles tenían el
derecho a defenderse si estaban siendo
atacados cabe recordar que arabia saudi
lidera una coalición que está luchando
contra los rebeldes hutíes en el yemen
desde 2015 siguiendo a la decisión de
riad también el reino de bahrein ha
llamado a su embajador a retirarse y ha
cortado las exportaciones el líbano
importa prácticamente todos sus
productos alimenticios por lo que esta
medida afectará todavía más la vida de
los libaneses que ya están sufriendo de
una escasez de alimentos de medicinas y
también de falta
a falta de electricidad es una ausencia
total ya que cortes de luz más de 20
horas diarias a esta nueva crisis
diplomática con los países del golfo ha
provocado una agitación política y ha
llevado a los partidos de la oposición a
pedir la dimisión del primer ministro
nayib mitaki el depuesto gobierno
sudanés advirtió este sábado que usar la
violencia en las grandes protestas
convocadas contra el golpe de estado
será contraproducente para los militares
ya iniciaron las movilizaciones que se
espera sean multitudinarias en jartúm la
capital del país por lo que el ejecutivo
disuelto tras el golpe de estado pidió a
las fuerzas armadas y a los servicios de
seguridad que frenen la violencia al
menos 11 personas han perdido la vida en
medio de protestas durante la última
semana eeuu hizo un llamado a respetar
los derechos humanos en el país
este 31 de octubre japón acudirá a las
urnas en la primera prueba real para el
nuevo primer ministro fumio kishida
algunos analistas creen que la
participación podría caer por debajo del
50% por primera vez la manera de
convencer a los votantes indiferentes
indecisos o simplemente enojados es un
gran desafío para los partidos japoneses
incluido el partido liberal democrático
que ha gobernado casi
ininterrumpidamente desde mediados de la
década de 1950
a pesar de ser candidata por primera vez
en las elecciones de la cámara baja de
japón moto con mis uno ve lo difícil que
es convencer a los votantes indiferentes
buenos días soy moto com/issue no estoy
obligada a presentarme primero la gente
tiene que saber qué tipo de persona soy
mucha gente va a trabajar en el metro
así que vine a la estación para
saludarlos los candidatos recorren sus
distritos electorales repitiendo
consignas a través de un altavoz como
madre soltera los antecedentes de mizuno
se consideran un obstáculo para ganar un
escaño en el parlamento de japón las
mujeres representan sólo el 10 por
ciento de los legisladores en la cámara
baja
y establecer un sistema de cuotas nos
permitiría lograr la igualdad de género
al menos en la política me temo que sin
eso las mujeres no estarán mejor
representadas
la apatía de muchos votantes es un
obstáculo para el cambio con el
parlamento dominado por hombres este
politólogo cree que los factores
culturales tienen mucho que ver y
se incita a la gente a pensar que es
mejor mantener un perfil bajo conseguir
buenos trabajos en lugar de intentar
cambiar la sociedad a través de la
acción política sienten que no tiene
sentido invertir tiempo y energía en
construir una alternativa al gobierno
actual
algunas encuestas sugieren que el
partido liberal-democrático perderá
escaños pero mantendrá su mayoría aunque
si la participación es tan baja algunos
se preguntan si contará con el apoyo del
pueblo japonés
en eeuu la autoridad de medicamentos y
alimentos a utilizar o autorizo casi de
forma unánime que la vacuna de facer by
ontex sea aplicada a niños entre 5 y 11
años la dosis que se les administrará
será inferior a la de los adultos para
evitar que los efectos secundarios sean
fuertes andrés granadillo nos amplía
luz verde para la vacuna de facer
variante que niños la decisión fue
tomada de forma abrumadora por la
administración de alimentos y
medicamentos de eeuu
efe
así que esto concluye la votación de los
18 miembros 17 votaron a favor y uno se
abstuvo de hardware en unos 28 millones
de niños estadounidenses entre 5 y 11
años que están regresando a clases
presenciales son elegibles para
aplicarse esta vacuna contra el jove y
19 según estudios clínicos de la
farmacéutica la vacuna tiene una
eficacia del 97 por ciento es la primera
en ser aprobada por eeuu para esta
población solo china cuba y los emiratos
árabes unidos han avalado vacunar a los
niños de estas edades claro si será la
tercera parte de la que se usa para los
adultos ya que según los expertos una
dosis más baja puede ayudar a que los
raros efectos secundarios sean menos
fuertes serán también dos dosis
aplicadas con tres semanas de diferencia
aunque aún falta que sea aprobada por
los centros para el control y la
prevención de enfermedades
ellos tienen previsto reunirse la
próxima semana
para mí la cuestión es muy clara no
queremos que los niños mueran por el
covite incluso si son menos niños que
adultos y no los queremos en la uci pero
las tasas de vacunación en eeuu no son
las mejores del mundo el 58% de los
ciudadanos de este país se han vacunado
completamente en comparación con francia
o reino unido donde han alcanzado a
inmunizar a más del 70% de la población
el pasado 26 de octubre ya un panel de
consejeros de la actual administración
de la casa blanca había recomendado la
autorización de la vacuna para los
menores la autorización no garantiza que
muchos padres lleven a sus hijos a los
centros de vacunación
vamos ahora a la isla española de la
palma donde esta mañana se registró un
sismo de 5,1 grados a 39 kilómetros de
profundidad se trata del movimiento
telúrico más fuerte desde que inició la
erupción del volcán cumbre vieja y de
acuerdo con expertos indica que nuevos
flujos de magma están abriendo paso
hacia la superficie lo que significa que
el volcán sigue altamente activo
y finalizamos en francia donde se lleva
a cabo el salón del chocolate el evento
más grande del mundo dedicado al cacao y
sus derivados desde versalles nuestra
periodista natalia ruiz nos dio más
detalles de esta muestra el chocolate se
toma a parís por espacio de un fin de
semana la idea de este salón es la de
caminar entre los cientos de stands que
muestran las diferentes preparaciones
los diferentes tipos de chocolate
algunas incluso de con sabores bastante
particulares pero más allá de esto
también se trata de un viaje a través
del mundo de quienes lo preparó la
característica de este cacao chuncho y
los granos de cacao es que incluso se
pueden consumir lo que se conoce como el
huevo kaká o el cacao crudo sin tostar y
para ello yo les puedo hacer una
demostración simplemente se se quita
la cáscara
yo puedo comérmelo y disfrutar
cuando se prueba el chocolate a la
primera probada usted dice guau qué es
esto porque no es amargo incluso a veces
la gente me pregunta si esto de
chocolate o si este yo les digo no el
chocolate pero hay una manera especial
de cocinarlo además de las degustaciones
y de los diferentes concursos la idea de
este salón también es demostrar que el
chocolate es algo muy noble con el cual
además pueden incluso hacerse obras de
arte hay varias esculturas en diferentes
stands de animales e incluso de gárgolas
como las que hay en otro adam de parís
una en relieve de napoleón bonaparte
pero quizás la que más impacto ha
causado es la que está justamente a mis
espaldas se trata de esta réplica del
guernica de picasso para esta obra se
necesitaron 500 kilogramos de chocolate
y fue fabricada por artesanos
chocolateros de francia y de españa a
ustedes muchas gracias por su sintonía
volvemos en breve con más información
aquí en france 24
[Música]